so you're probably wondering after you
clicked on this video why exactly do I
need to buy a Wii U well if you haven't
picked one up I gotta tell you this
Nintendogs still has some tricks up its
sleeve here's four reasons why you
should buy wii u this holiday season
number four virtual console and
backwards compatibility the wii u has
the largest back catalogue of all
current consoles wii game discs and
purchased we where in Virtual Console
games are compatible meaning you have
the entire week game library available
and at your feet so if you missed out on
Super Mario Galaxy one or two or any
other wii game you didn't get to play or
if you have virtual console purchases
from your wii you still want to access
you are covered number three the price
the Wii U is also the cheapest of all
three current-gen consoles coming in at
299 bucks that price usually includes at
least one great nintendo game bundled in
like Super Mario maker splatoon Mario
Kart 8 and more so you can get home plug
it in and start playing without spending
any extra cash and you'll want those
extra dollars in your wallet because of
my next point number two amiibo yes
amiibo in my opinion they offer the best
bang for your buck and the toys to life
category because they work across games
on the Wii U as opposed to being locked
into a specific title Nintendo's already
sold over 21 million of these little
guys since their introduction in
mid-2014 so there's definitely something
great happening here honestly if there's
a hero in a nintendo game it probably
has an amoeba plus they look awesome on
your shelf and our number one reason to
buy OVU is first party exclusives every
console has its exclusives we know but
nobody does exclus
nintendo you'll only be able to play the
latest full-fledged Mario or legend of
zelda game on a Nintendo console and if
you don't check them out you're missing
out on some of the best games the
industry has to offer mario kart 8
Bayonetta 2 platoon Pikmin 3 Super Smash
Brothers Super Mario maker Super Mario
3d World anything with super I on the
title all incredibly solid titles from
the house of in it's true that
nintendo's new console codenamed NX is
just around the corner but we don't even
have an announcement much less are
releasing so when you consider the four
points i just made you kind of me nuts
not to have wii u in your house I mean
Greg games great price great add-ons
just do it and if you do maybe i'll see
you in inkopolis you know because i have
a splatoon
you